I am just a regular girl with a regular life, but huge dreams.
I live in the city but I love nature.
I love a lot of things, you know.
God, family, animals, music, writing, photography, art, movies.
Love is certainly an inspiration for everything I do.
And yes, sometimes I feel I'm lost...
...and I don't know which path to take, and I want to give up.
But then I realize, so what if I fail?
I'm alive, I can keep trying and do what I want.
At least I won't say, what if I had done this or that?
Life is exciting.
You can shape it, change what you don't like,...
...make it better, do something big, you know.
The sky's the limit.
I want to enjoy everything, big or small.
I don't wanna miss all those little happy moments, waiting for something else.
I have so many dreams and only one life, and I feel like mine is just starting.
This is my chance.
And that's me.